here now for reaction congressman and
north carolina senate candidate ted budd
along with
new york post columnist carol markowitz
good to see you both congressman since
you have the mba
let me start with you the only people
who are happy tonight
are the lawyers right as we speak
they're they're they're buying portions
uh because they know this litigation is
going to finance their lavish lifestyle
for years to come but doesn't it all
come down
to fraud
were there intentional
misrepresentations and false statements
that led to a material breach of the
contract what say you
well greg this is a 44 billion dollar
deal with a billion dollar breakup fee
uh if uh there's uh not material reason
but elon musk thinks that there is uh
he's finding out that twitter no
surprise to us that are conservatives is
just not being transparent about their
business practices this is one of the
reasons that i'm running for u.s senate
it's one of the reasons that we have to
hold big tech accountable it's one of
the reasons we have to take a good look
at cda section 230 or the communications
decency act of section 230. i've got a
plan for this it's something i've been
working on for years and i'd like to do
that in the us senate and my plans up on
tedbud.com
yeah i mean listen i totally agree with
you uh giving liability protection um
is insane maybe it may made sense at one
point in time a couple of decades ago at
the outset of the internet but uh
uh carol let me go to you on this you
know i liken it to buying a car
um if the seller knows it's a lemon with
a history of problems but claims it's a
wonderful car
and never had an issue
then the buyer is being defrauded here
and anybody who has ever used twitter or
pays attention to it knows that five
percent fake accounts and spam and bots
is ludicrous it's way more than that
what do you think
way more yeah absolutely i'm an avid
twitter user there's no doubt about it
that that number is far higher you know
a few months ago
some leftist activists tried to buy a
pillow company to compete with my pillow
the conservative you know pillow company
and it completely failed their whole
thing fell apart and you know a lot of
people on twitter got to laugh at them i
think the idea of elon musk buying
twitter is not at all like that this is
a man who knows what he's doing this is
not like he had a shot in the dark
decided to buy some random company and
didn't think it through at all so i
think the fact that he's pulling back
from this deal right now says that he
knows something that can you know
potentially lead to uh maybe a
negotiating a better price or something
like that that maybe he'll still buy the
app i wouldn't be surprised um if that
does happen and but if it doesn't i
wouldn't be surprised if elon is next to
get banned you know hot gulag somewhere
for conservatives
you know i checked uh the stock price
it's hovering around 36 the the offer
was for 54
uh a share so i what do you think
congressman budd i mean i think carol's
on to something here this is a ploy to
lower the purchase price
look i think he's finding real problems
in there about the business practices of
twitter they're not being transparent
with him they're obviously not being
transparent with their users or with
conservatives i mean greg how is it that
the ayatollah of iran can be on there
but they've banned a former president
when even their oversight board of
twitter said that the former president
shouldn't be permanently banned i mean
back you mentioned the early start of
the internet back when we were getting
those cd roms if we can if we're old
enough to remember in the mail hoping
that we would sign up for aol online
well we did and by golly you know cda
section 230 was good in 1996
but they these big tech platforms had
their cake and ate it too uh that's very
unfortunate that they got the benefits
of a platform but decided to act as
publisher and start censoring things
when we were hoping for more free speech
and that's what elon musk wants he wants
more free speech for americans and for
the world which is better for democracy
for the republic and he wants more
transparency from uh the the leaders at
twitter and he's not getting it
you know carol they got to be popping
their champagne corks over at twitter
tonight
they can now resume
their unfettered censorship right
yeah absolutely you know there was some
covertly taken videos out by project
veritas recently where we saw that
twitter employees were very openly
calling themselves communist and saying
yeah it's a very calming organization so
i imagine that there are a lot of
employees who are happy about this i
can't imagine that you know shareholders
are very happy about this this seems
like a disaster for most people who own
twitter stock um so it remains to be
seen who wins at the end of this i don't
know my money's still on elon not
necessarily that he's going to buy it
but then he comes out on top here
yeah
well i can tell you the tesla investors
we're not happy about is devoting so
much attention to twitter we'll see how
this thing washes out congressman you're
running for the senate good luck to you
uh carol great to see you as always
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else